our next speaker is sergio rotella
professor of cancer immunotherapy in the
university of nottingham trend
she will discuss how immune infiltration
correlates with p53 mutational status in
the eml
hello my name is sergio vela i work at
nottingham trent university
in england i wish to thank the meeting
organizers for giving us the opportunity
to present today
on immune correlates of tp53 mutation of
status in acute malory leukemia
this is my disclosure slide which
relates to
research support from microgenics
nanostring technologies
and cure oncology
my lab in nottingham is currently
working on the high dimensional analysis
of the aml immunological tumor
microenvironment
using targeted immune gene expression
profiling on the encounter nanostream
platform
but also geomics digital spatial
profiling
to try and elucidate the topography of
the immune infiltrate and how
this may correlate with immunotherapy
responses
we also have an interest in defining the
oncogenic pathways
that may drive immunological
infiltration in aml and this includes of
course tp53
which will be the main focus of my
presentation today
let me provide you with some background
on aml
so chemotherapy remains the standard of
care for most patients with aml
despite recent approvals of nova drugs
primary refractory or chemotherapy
resistant disease as defined by
failure to achieve complete remission of
cr
occurs in 10 to 40 percent of the
patient population
and the five-year overall survival from
first relapse for patients with aml is
only 20
so the investigation of new molecularly
targeted and immunomodulating
agents remains a high priority for the
field
and there is an urgent need for
predictive biomarkers to help
identify patients who are more likely to
respond to cancer immunotherapy
and we have recently identified the
tumor inflammation
signature as a good predictor of
response to fetidism and immunotherapy
in aml
so this slide summarizes our recent work
that used immune gene expression
profiling of 290 bone marrow samples
from patients with chemotherapy naive
aml
this analysis identified three distinct
gene expression profile
namely an interferon dominant profile
including high expression of interferon
gamma
pl1 pdl2 inflammatory chemokines and
interferon downstream signaling
molecules
an adaptive profile including high
expression of t
cell b cell and natural killer cell
markers
and the myeloid profile including high
abundance of neutrophils
macrophages and other cells of the
myeloid lineage
this course will then use in aggregate
to stratify
patients with aml into an immune
infiltrated and immune depleted subgroup
as shown in panel a in this slide
in patients in the immune infiltrated
subgroup had
higher levels of interferon stimulated
genes
t-cell and cytotoxicity markers
molecules implicated in
antigen processing presentation as well
as actionable
immune checkpoints such as pdl1
btla ctla4 and team3
and as shown by the rock values in panel
c
interferon related rna profiles improve
our ability to predict
resistance to chemotherapy compare with
the
cytogenetic risk classifier which is
still the gold standard in the clinic
we also uh used as i recently mentioned
a geomics digital spatial profile
to identify protein co-localization
patterns with potential prognostic
relevance
in t-cell infiltrated aml this highly
multiplexed technology
allowed us to quantify 31 immune
oncology related proteins
in 10 bone marrow ffpes from patients
with
newly diagnosed chemotherapy naive aml
as shown in panel a in this slide we
analyze the 240
geometric regions of interest roi's
with varying degrees of t cell
infiltration and we identified
uh prognostic seven protein signature
which
is referred to as signature 3 in panel b
and includes cytotoxicity molecules such
as bronzing b
fox b3 pdl1 as well as stat 3 and bcl2
when evaluated in silico our protein
signature
was deregulated at the rna level in
approximately one-fourth of tcga
aml patients who mostly clustered in the
immune infiltrated subgroup
as shown in the mutation enrichment plot
in panel b
the regulation of signature three genes
is significantly correlated with
typically three mutational status
and approximately 55 percent of the
patients with
tp53 abnormalities in tcga aml
had the missense mutation as summarized
in penalty
aml patients with the regulated levels
of signature three genes
tended to have adverses at the genetic
risk as shown in panel a
and had significantly shorter relapse
free survival in the overall survival
as suggested by the kaplan mayor
estimates
in panel b
so to summarize this first part of my
talk and the preliminary work
that we've done in this area we
identified an experimentally derived
protein signature which
is associated with a new infiltrated aml
with
tp53 mutations and ultimately with poor
clinical outcomes
we therefore asked the question whether
tb53 could be a new genetic driver of
immune filtration in aml
so let me provide you with a background
of the stasis of tp63 mutations
specifically in aml so these
abnormalities are known to occur in
eight to ten percent of de novo aml
cases
and are associated with chemotherapy
resistance with high risk of relapse
and with this small prognosis even after
hematopoietic sensor transplantation
the functional consequences of typical
mutation in activation of enhanced
immunological responses
have been largely overlooked in aml the
tp53 mutants
studied thus far in aml do not show any
evidence of gain of functioning
mechanisms
with the four asked the question whether
or not tp53 abnormalities may correlate
with the composition and functional
orientation
of the tumor immunological
microenvironment in aml
so to be able to answer this question we
initially downloaded
rna sequencing data from tcga again a
collection of
147 cases of non-chromyositic aml
including 14 patients with tp53
mutations
we then computed immune cell type
specific and
biological activity gene signatures as
predefined
linear combinations of biologically
relevant gene sets
which were then correlated with
prognostic molecular lesions including
tp53 mutational stages
nucleophosmine 1 and pm1 mutational
status
3 itd mutational status and cheap
defining mutations and ultimately with
clinical outcomes
we also provide primary bone marrow
samples from 42
treatment naive patients with tp53
mutated aml and 22
treatment naive patients with tp53 wild
type aml
using the pan cancer io 360 panel from
landscaping technology
and finally in the translational
component of this study
we analyzed primary bone marrow samples
from 35
patients with relapsed refractory aml
who were treated with flutitudement
11 patients in this cohort had either
tp53 mutations or 17p
abnormalities with genomic loss of tp53
so moving to the next slide panel a here
shows unsupervised hierarchical
clustering of
44 immune gene signatures in 118 tcga
cases with non-promylocytic aml and
available information on prognostic
molecular lesions
including 14 patients with tp53
mutations
two patients subgroups were clearly
identified namely patients with immune
infiltrated ammon
in patients with immune depleted aml
compare with tcga aml cases with
favorable risk
and intermediate risk molecular lesions
all patients
with tp53 mutations show high levels of
immune infiltration
and had higher tumor inflammation
signature scores
inflammatory chemokine scores
interphenol gamma syndrome scores and
lymphoid scores as summarized in panel b
in particular the expression of immune
checkpoints pdl1 and digit
and also molecules associated with an
immune suppressed tumor
environment such as the t-reg
transcription factor fox p3
were significantly higher in tp53
mutated patients as summarized in panel
c
and in line with previous findings the
kepler mayor estimates
of survival for patients with dp53
mutated aml were
significantly shorter compared with tcga
cases
harboring other risk defining molecular
lesions
we next profiled pre-treatment bone
marrow samples from 42
patients with tp53 mutated aml
as shown in panel a most patients in
this cohort
have missense mutations of tp53 which
are often associated with
dp53 loss of function principle
component analysis in panel b highlights
the immune cell type specific
scores and biological activities course
distinguished
patients with typical 53 mutated aml
from individuals with tp53 wild type aml
as shown by unsupervised hierarchical
clustering
of immune chain signature scores in
panel c
the frequency of tp63 mutated cases was
87
75 and 8 respectively
in patients with high intermediate and
low levels of immune infiltration
and also in line with our encyclical
analysis of tcga
aml cases immune checkpoints video one
and fox p53
a molecule recently associated with
features of t-cell senescence and t-cell
exhaustion
were more highly expressed in patients
with tp53 mutated aml
compared with dp-53 wild-type aml
we next analyze the immune transmitomic
profile at the gene level
and we identify the set of 34
differentially expressed
immune related genes between patients
with mutated and wild type
aml as shown in panels a and panel b
we will refer to this set of
differentially expressed genes as
tp53 in your gene classifier
the tp53 immune signature genes have not
been previously implicated in the tp-53
signaling pathway
as shown in the venn diagram by the lack
of any overlap with hallmark
dp53 gene sets downloaded from the
molecular
signature database
the differentially expressed molecules
exhibited enrichment of
keg pathways related to cytokine
cytokine receptor interactions
autoimmune inflammatory processes and
il17 mediated and tnf-mediated signaling
as shown in panels a and b
we then assessed the differential
expressed genes in silico
for potential prognostic value in tcga
aml cases
abnormalities in d19 in new genes that
were overexpressed
in patients with tp53 mutated aml
by default rna upregulation gene
amplification
deep deletion missense mutations
significantly correlated with wars
relapse-free survival and overall
survival estimates
as shown by the couple of major curves
in panel c
by contrast the 15 immune genes that
were downgraduated in patients with tb53
mutated aml
carried no prognostic significance and
these data
are not shown here today
so we moved to the translational element
of this work and we asked whether
tp53 abnormalities may identify a
subgroup of patients with aml
that may benefit from immunotherapy with
flutter suits
times cd3 by specific dart molecule for
redirecting host t
cells to aml in the cpemgd00601
clinical trial
so this slide summarizes the clinical
characteristics of the
35 patients in the floriditsuma cohort
median age at time of study entry was 54
years
57 of these patients had primary
induction failure
as defined by failure to respond to two
or more induction attempts
and 17 percent of them had early relapse
of aml
according less than six months after the
achievement of complete remission
70 percent of the patients had an
unfavorable
cytogenetic risk based on the 2017 elm
classification
response in this study was assessed in
terms of anti-leukemic activity ala
which was defined as either complete
remission complete remission with
partial hematopoietic recovery
partial response other benefit
more than 30 percent decreasing bone
marrow blasts compared to baseline
and non-responders were defined as
either treatment failure
stable disease or progressive disease
baseline bone marrow samples for immune
gene expression profiling were available
in
nine out of 11 patients with tp53
mutations and or genomic loss
of stp-53 among this seven patients
showed intermediate to high immune
infiltration as highlighted by the heat
map in panel a
time and treatment in time to patient
death and or censoring
are summarized in panel b for patients
with dp53 mutations and or 17p
abnormalities
including two patients who proceeded to
receive halogenate in metabolic sensor
transplantation
overall antibiotic activity was
documented in 45.5
5 out of 11 available patients with
tp53 mutations and or 17p abnormalities
so the reduction of bone marrow blasts
in
10 patients with tp53 abnormalities for
whom
a post-treatment bone marrow sample was
available
averaged 42 percent as shown in panel a
in tp53 mutated patients with evidence
of anti-locating activity from logitism
up
the tumor inflammation signature score
inflammatory chemokine score
t-rex score and interferon gamma c
learning score
were significantly higher at baseline
compared with non-responders as
summarized in panel b and again
highlighting the association between
response to diesel engagers
the t-cell inflamed tumor
microenvironment
media were all survival from study study
entry was
four months for patients with tp53
mutated
aml or 17p abnormalities as shown in
panel c
and this survival estimate compares
favorably
with survival predictions for tp53
mutated patients
with primary induction failure median
overall survival of 1.16 months
in large aml series such as the hobon
cohort as
shown in panel d and finally
further in silicon analysis also
suggested that media overall survival
is not dissimilar between newly
diagnosed hormone cases with dp53
mutations
three point 58 months and have owned
cases with wild type
tp63 and primary induction failure
3.78 months panel e
so in conclusion immune transfer atomic
analysis of in silicon and white lab
cohorts of
tp63 mutated aml suggests the presence
of high t cell infiltration
and high expression of immune
checkpoints and interferon gamma
signaling molecules
compared with aml subgroups with other
risk defining molecular lesions
experimentally derived tp53 related
immune chain signatures
are significant for survival prediction
in aml
and finally immunotherapy with floating
tutoring has shown efficacy
in individuals with altered tp-53 status
with an overall reduction of bone marrow
blasts averaging 42 percent and with
evidence of anti-leukemic activity
in 45.5 of the patients
and i wish to conclude my presentation
by thanking co-authors and collaborators
the special mention goes to my
colleagues uh ian davidson moncada
microgenex and sarah church and
nanostream technologists
for the fantastic support to all of this
thank you very much for listening
what is the recommended input of rna for
the analysis of bone marrow samples
yeah i'm ready so the recommended
input of rna for the analysis of bone
marrow samples would be between 100
and 150 nanograms per email this is what
we have used consistently with
excellent results in terms of quality
controls
did you use purified leukemia blast in
your experiments
so we did not use purified aml blast in
our study because the main objective of
this was
to get a comprehensive overview of the
bone marrow
infiltrate which of course includes
immune cells so all of these studies
were performed using
unseparated bone marrow preparations
is there any evidence from solid tumors
that p53 mutations
associated with response to
immunotherapy
i'm ready so there is actually evidence
that solid tumors with tb53 mutation may
be i mean able to respond to
immunotherapy there are very good
studies published in patients with lung
cancer showing that individuals with
tb53 mutations have higher levels of
immune checkpoints
and they tend to be more responsive to
pl1 p1 blocking strategies
are other genetic drivers of cancer
associated with the whole tumor
microenvironment
there is evidence that other genetic
drivers may correlate with a t cell
inflamed or
interferon gamma dominant immune
microenvironment this is evidence
again published in the field of lung
cancers patients with mutations in k
rats and brass tend to have higher
levels of interference related molecules
and again it could be
particularly responsive to immunotherapy
so this multi-cohort aml study used
a variety of highly multiplexed
technologies
including targeted immune expression
profiling and protein profiling
to dissect the immunological landscape
of aml
the study identified patients within an
infiltrated aml and immune depleted aml
and these immune landscapes were shown
to be highly predictive of
responses to current treatment including
chemotherapy and immunotherapy
and particularly patients with db53
mutated aml
tend to have very high levels of tissue
infiltration
and high expression of actionable immune
checkpoints including pdl1 and digit
and also increased expression of
interferon gamma signaling molecules
compared with aml subgroups with other
molecular lesions
we identified an experimentally derived
dp53 related immune gene signature
which we used in silicon to determine
whether these genes have any prognostic
relevance and this was the case
so patients with higher expression of
tb53 related immune genes
tend to have a worse prognosis when
treated with conventional treatments
including chemotherapy
and finally our study also wanted to
explore whether
immune profiles can be used to predict
response to a novel immunotherapy agent
named flotiditsuma which targets cd123
on aml cells in cd3 on t
cells and our study in 35
patients with chemotherapy refractory
aml showed that patients with
increased levels of interferon gamma
related molecules tend to respond to
fluttershy demand